what's the most beautiful idea in
computer science or theoretical computer
science to you like what just
early on in your life or in general i've
captivated you and just grabbed you
i think i'm gonna have to go with the
idea of universality
uh you know if you're really asking for
the most beautiful
i mean uh so universality
is the idea that you know you put
together a few simple operations
like in the case of boolean logic that
might be the and gate the or gate the
not
gate right and then your first guess is
okay this is a good start
but obviously as i want to do more
complicated things i'm going to need
more complicated building blocks to
express
that right and and that was actually my
guess when i first learned what
programming was
i mean when i was you know an adolescent
and i someone showed me uh
uh apple basic and then you know gw
basic if any any anyone listening
remembers that
okay but uh you know i thought okay well
now you know i mean i mean i
i thought i felt like um this is a
revelation
you know it's like finding out where
babies come from it's like that level of
you know why didn't
anyone tell me this before right but i
thought okay this is just the beginning
now i know how to write a basic program
but to you know really write a an
interesting program
like a you know a video game which had
always been my my dream as a kid to you
know
create my own nintendo games right that
you know but
i mean obviously i'm gonna need to learn
some way more complicated form of
programming than that
okay but you know eventually i learned
this incredible idea of universality
and that says that no you throw in a few
rules
and then you can you already have enough
to express everything
okay so for example the and the or and
the not
gate uh can all or in fact even just the
and the not gate
or even just even just the nand gate for
example
uh is already enough to express any
boolean function on any number of bits
you just have to string together enough
of them so you can build a universe with
nand gates you can build the universe
out of nand gates yeah
uh you know the the simple instructions
of basic
are already enough at least in principle
you know if we ignore details like how
much memory can be accessed and stuff
like that
that is enough to express what could be
expressed by any programming language
whatsoever
and the way to prove that is very simple
we simply need to show
that in basic or whatever we could write
a
an interpreter or a compiler for
whatever
other programming language we care about
like c or or
java or whatever and as soon as we had
done that then ipso facto
anything that's expressible in c or java
is also expressible and basic
okay and so this idea of universality
you know goes back at least to alan
turing in the 1930s
when you know he uh um wrote down this
incredibly simple pared down model of a
computer
the touring machine right which uh you
know he paired down the instruction set
to just
read a symbol you know go write a symbol
move to the left move to the right uh
halt change your internal state
right that's it simple okay and anybody
proved that um
you know this could simulate all kinds
of other things
uh you know and so so in fact today we
would say
well we would call it a touring
universal model of computation
that is you know just as it has just the
same expressive power
that basic or uh java or c
plus or any of those other languages
have because anything in those other
languages could be compiled down
to touring machine now touring also
proved a different related thing
which is that there is a single touring
machine
that can simulate any other touring
machine
if you uh uh just describe that other
machine on its tape
right and likewise there is a single
touring machine
that will run any c program you know if
you just put it on its tape
that that's a second meaning of
universality
first of all that he couldn't visualize
it and that was in the 30s yeah i think
the 30s that's right before
computers really i mean um
i don't know how i wonder what that felt
like
uh you know learning that there's no
santa claus or something uh
uh because i i don't know if that's
empowering or paralyzing
because it it doesn't uh give you any
ins it's a
like you can't write a software
engineering book and make that
the first chapter and say we're done
well i mean i mean
right i mean i mean in in one sense it
was this enormous flattening of the
universe
yes right i had imagined that there was
going to be some infinite hierarchy
of more and more powerful programming
languages
you know and then i kicked myself for
you know for having such a stupid idea
but
apparently girdle had had the same
conjecture in the 30s oh good and then
you know you're in good company
well yeah and and then and then tour and
then girdle read toring's paper
and he kicked himself and he said yeah i
was completely wrong about that
okay but um um but you know i had
thought that you know
maybe maybe where i can contribute will
be to invent a new more powerful
programming language that lets you
express
things that could never be expressed in
basic yeah right
you know and then you know how would you
do that obviously you couldn't do it
itself in basic right
but uh uh but you know there is this
incredible flattening that happens once
you learn what is universality
but then it's also um uh like
um an opportunity because it means once
you know these rules
then you know the sky is the limit right
then you have kind of the same
weapons at your disposal that the
world's greatest programmer has
it's now all just a question of how you
wield them right exactly
but so every problem is solvable
but some problems are harder than others
and well yeah there's the question of
how much time
you know well of how hard is it to write
a program
and then there's also the questions of
what resources does the program need
you know how much time how much memory
those are much more complicated
questions of course ones that we're
still struggling with today
you